good day my name is tj hills
and uh i am a patient advocate and i'm
here to talk to you today
about estrogen metabolism dysfunction
and treatment as it
is related to precision or genetic
testing
um i'd like to start out just telling
you a little bit about myself
because i am not a physician and i am
not in the medical field
except as a patient advocate i was
diagnosed with stage 2b
or now 3 breast cancer in 2009
at the time i had absolutely no family
history both
extended or immediate
and it was um
like a a jolt to the entire family
uh i did not like my prognosis ads i was
told that if
um i did everything that everyone told
me to
successfully that i would have a 30
chance of recurrence
in five years and if i did not do any
treatment i would have a 70
chance of death within five years
uh so i found that pretty disturbing i
had two
young children three actually young
children
and so i started studying adjunct
treatment
and my background is actually in
political science and finance
i have run a company
specializing in financial research and
political risk for over 25 years
and so while i did not know a lot about
medicine
i do know quite a bit about statistics
and so i was able to train myself to
read
studies and to interpret the information
and decide for myself
uh what was important or not now i live
in new york city
uh and so i because of my proximity to
some of the best hospitals in the world
had access to a lot of cutting-edge
research at the time i had access to
a lot of experimentation and cell stem
cell treatments
in cancer vaccines some very innovative
treatments going on it was the very
early stages
of immunotherapy and
at the time though i met a biochemist
and began to study estrogen metabolism
and i decided to choose that as my
adjunct treatment
i found it along with some other women
the hormonal cancer foundation and then
more recently
the better estrogen foundation my
website where
i promote myself for public speaking
so that i may inform physicians and
women about estrogen metabolism function
particularly as it affects breast cancer
is at betterestrogen.com
and i ran the estrogen gene test company
for several years
a little bit more about me again i was
age 44
at the time of my diagnosis i had no
family history
i went through as much of standard
treatment as i could but
i was unable to maintain a white blood
cell count even with
all of the help and so finally my
treatment was aborted a little bit early
after repeated hospitalizations i did a
full course of
radiation and then i began to mexican
and after all of that i joined an
estrogen metabolism study and i started
nutritional supplementation to improve
my estrogen function
later when it became available uh i had
oncotype testing which showed that i had
a 15
recurrence risk which still uh did not
make me
uh uh relieved
so uh the learning objection objectives
for
this presentation are to learn about
estrogen metabolism
uh dysfunction gene testing uh
exogenous and angiogenesis estrogen
exposure and how it relates to breast
cancer
as well as the nutritional interventions
that may improve estrogen function the
critical patient populations which
require testing
and i'd like to talk about what i
advocate
is a new standard of care for owen
and then most of my time will be spent
on case studies
if you uh this is a diverse audience i
understand
and so if you would like to study more
of the background information there is
a lot of information references favorite
studies of mine
in the physician area of my website and
if you would like a full
refresher course on estrogen metabolism
my former chief scientific officer
and partner dr joe beltman has
many hours of that in the estrogen gene
test company
physician training videos area
so i am going to very quickly speed
through
a review of um a little bit of the
background before proceeding to case
studies
and you know just to make sure we're all
on the same page
there are often they're often when
you're talking about gene testing and
breast cancer
is is an automatic assumption
about hereditary predisposition
for breast cancer and that is not at all
what i'm talking about in fact um
i'm only talking about estrogen
metabolism
uh function the reason this slide is
here is just to show
that you know 80 of all breast cancer
patients have no
family history any form of breast cancer
and 75 of all breast cancer is fueled
by estrogen
i think it's pretty well known but for
those of you who don't spend
a lot of time studying breast cancer
one of the most common the common
denominator
in breast cancer risk factors is as much
overall
estrogen exposure and so one of the
reasons we have an increase
in breast cancer is simply because of
longevity
the older you are the greater your risk
of
cancer is in the and the reason for that
in this particular uh estrogen receptor
positive cancers
is because of your overall estrogen
exposure increases with your age
so to the normal list this is from
breast cancer organism
breastcancer.org
i would add also old birth control pills
in addition to hormonal replacement
therapy and infertility medications and
that is specifically as it relates to
women who have an estrogen metabolism
dysfunction
so i think i think the important thing
to note about this
is that everything on this list
especially
if you are you know living in america
and let's say you're a middle-aged woman
you've had extensive exposure to
photoestrogens
but everything apart from that and that
is what i would call a normal natural
exposure now in the united states
um is is a
a what i would call a natural thing
you're a woman you age you have your
regular family histories your grace your
ethnicity whether you're
overweight however your how many babies
you have how long you breastfeed or if
you breastfeed at all what age you get
your period you know these are natural
things and so
uh i think they the objective here
is to ascertain which if 12
of all women in the united states will
wind up with some form of a
breast cancer diagnosis that means 10
of those women will have an estrogen
related
or few breast cancer which means there's
90
of these women in the united states who
these factors don't apply to and i think
that it's important for us to use this
information
in genetic testing to ascertain who's
really more at risk or not
so just to be clear and i'm going to
rush through these
because we have a limited amount of time
and
if you are interested in the
biochemistry behind this i encourage you
to go to either one of those websites
but uh in this slide um
you see to the right hand side this is
the part of estradiol
which tamoxifen and aromatase inhibitors
are
effectively
effectively decreasing breast cancer
mortality because they
are binding to
the estrogen receptor and blocking that
action
what we're focusing on but nonetheless a
standard
breast cancer diagnosis still leaves
a significant recurrence risk and so
what we're focusing on is the other
pathway which is the metabolism
which is on the left hand side of this
chart
and that is what the rest of this
presentation
is focusing on and i'm not i'm not going
to belabor this but i do want to talk
about the
genes that control that left-hand side
of the part
so you have three families and
all genetic testing companies who offer
this commercially
are only looking at modifiable genes um
you have the cyp family uh you have comt
and you have the gs
gst family and those are the three as
well as the mnsod and
each genetic testing company has a
variant of this depending on
how recently their test was formed the
most current research
but those those are the overall the
overall types of genes families that
we're looking at
and what we're trying to do the
objective here is to
increase a woman's ability to
effectively
excrete through urine and sweat
to the green areas
so again this is the chemical
action of what happens when you have a
mutation on
one of these genes
um i like there's there's a lot of
information in both of the websites i
apologize
um i like this particular
uh study because it is a pooled
study with 427 controls 427 breast
cancer patients which shows
that the more mutations on those
families of genes
and combine with the more estrogen
exposure will result in the more
breast cancer
and this this chart
is um also able to see and
what's you know visually impactful here
is that you'll see that women who have
less than three mutations on these
on these genes um are are
healthy less at risk and then the
profiles of both the women
at high risk and the women with breast
cancer are essentially identical
so what it isn't that tips women over
the edge and that is typically
their uh exogenous
or endogenous as exposure
so in in these families we're looking at
um
only modifiable genes um
and depend this is one particular paper
this is the
old paper there have been others which
update
update this uh but depending on race
depending on the genes looked at
the numbers change but for example in
this paper
uh depending on the amount of mutations
you have and the combination of those
thereof
uh your your your risk breast cancer
risk could be
uh anywhere from double to 13.
and where i'd like to focus uh for the
rest of our time together
is on the multiple options that you have
available to improve
the genetic athlete function so
in general we're looking at dim which is
dim indol3 carbinol uh cruciferous
vegetable mixes which are available on
the market
uh any any form of potent antioxidant
all physicians tend to have their
preference mega
doses of vitamin c um
nac and as well as sami which is
you know available over the encounter as
are everything else there's also
uh fish oils which are
which are a part of the uh part of part
of the
intervention so
uh the rest of our our time is going to
be spent
on how how getting this testing
can result in a clinical clinical
decision making
do you have a few sips do you have does
your patient have a few snips
have they had prior estrogen exposure do
they have many steps
or are they breast cancer
so i feel pretty strongly that
uh all women should have estrogen
metabolism genetics
and ideally i think that that new
protocol for care should happen
before a woman is sexually active
because this information would allow
any woman to plan essentially her
lifelong fertility cycle
uh if she took birth control pills are
very different than they used to be in
the past so
that is not at this time known to be
terribly impactful but nonetheless if
you have a
13 year old girl who you've had tested
and you find that she has
every single mutation or deletion
in her profile then perhaps you would
not want to prescribe
a young girl um with uh
even the very low dose birth but that
that's a complicated question and
it is sufficiently low dose to uh
to to be administered but perhaps with
caution so i think that this testing
really allows physicians to treat their
their patients on an individual basis it
would allow physician
confidence in prescribing hormonal
replacement therapy or bioidentical
hormones
whether or not a person should have 12
rounds of fertility treatments whether
or not she should delay having
childbirth
and how critically any patient has to be
watched in terms of her
lifelong breast cancer risk and the
interventions are simple
however um the that
that's that's my personal goal but the
critical populations that
should be tested really should be tested
or anyone who has breast
prostate ovarian or endometrial cancers
themselves or in their family anyone who
has had
significant exposure to hormone
replacement therapy bioidentical
hormones fertility medications or
old birth control pills um 20 years of
old birth control pills for example
polycystic ovarian syndrome patients
those with fibroid tumors
and severe acne which requires
medication all of those
estrogen metabolism dysfunction is
implicated
in conditions and one of the big
very very clear symbols of the
dysfunction is irregular bleeding
that is almost
where
where we are i'm going to talk about
myself for quite a long time when we get
to it but
what i am advocating is that
physicians do a estrogen metabolism
extended family history in order to
assess
um if if those dysfunctions are running
in the family
uh estrogen exposure history is is
standard
standard care already that every every
woman have
the metabolism gene test and that allows
the physician to determine individual
risk
and that will allow a physician to
easily inform their estrogen medications
prescriptions for example there's a lot
of physicians who will really hesitate
to
prescribe hrt or bioidentical hormones
uh
since since the women's health
initiative
and if everyone had this chest
uh i believe that prescriptions would go
back up because most women would
actually be unclear
and the the the ability
to alter the genomic pathways is easy
the the interventions are easy they're
non-toxic
and the dosing of those interventions
can be monitored with
metabolites
and uh before i digress i'm just going
to show an example
of my former company's
mutations uh genetic testing is
available in genocides
which is in austria genova diagnostics
has an old test that was the one i
originally took
um dna life which is part of nordic
laboratories has a test
toolbox genomics there's a few other
companies oftentimes
the genetic the estrogen metabolism
mutations will be classified
under detoxification panels
and they can be used as well
and so in this particular chart what
we're showing is
uh the interventions which improve the
the
function so dim pro or
you know the indole-3-carbinol for those
who
don't prefer uh the stability of jim
crow um
jim crow indole-3-carbinol cruciferous
vegetables
fish oils sammy and
an antioxidant of choice
uh those protocols would also include
keeping a low bmi
if at all possible as uh
sometimes obesity could deter the
results of tamoxifen
and aromatase inhibitor or or these
interventions as well
estrogen is is produced
in the fat cells endogenous estrogen
and so obesity is a factor
as potent in some cases as as taking
estrogenic medications
so uh that is one of the prescriptions
for
improving estrogen health as well
so i'm just going to talk about myself
let me check
how much time i have left i am going to
talk about
uh what happened to me evelyn
so uh what happened to me is that i
went through three extremely strong
um extremely strong uh
ivf treatments fertility treatments and
i participated in between
uh in between result two and three
of the treatments in a very high dose
dhea
study for for a few months which was
supposed to
improve my my ovarian function
and after i completed
those three treatments about a year
later approximately i began
having irregular bleeding which i had
never had before
um and this um
this became more severe and more severe
and i started to see obgyns
and most of the physicians just
diagnosed me as perimenopausal at the
time
i was 41 42 43 years old
and although none of the blood work
confirmed that i was anywhere close to
period
and my mother and her sisters had begun
menopause at
traditional ages between 53-55
and you know i was very busy running my
company and i would have continued to
ignore my irregular bleeding but the
irregular
bleeding was making my migraines
uncontrollable
and so i kept going to different doctors
so that i could continue my very high
functioning
alpha life and um
the only thing i was eventually offered
was a birth control bill which i didn't
want to take because i knew it made my
migraines work
but i finally tried it and um
and that was really disastrous um
and finally my husband put me in touch
insisted i see this integrated position
uh pretty close to our home and she
started me on end all three carbinol
which was the first time
where the bleeding began to regulate
however
it was too late because uh about two
months or so
after i began that treatment and and
started
attending that obgyn practice um my lump
was found
and so one of the things that really
motivates me in my work here to promote
uh estrogen gene test function is what
if
originally when i first started having a
regular bleeding and first started
seeing physicians
if i had been put on the interventions
if i had been
you know my case history had been
taken my family history and
my genetic background and i had had
these
uh interventions um put
into play at that earlier stage
what would have happened would i have
developed
the aggressive breast cancer that i have
or not
so uh going back to me so now we can add
uh 20 years of old birth control pills
three rounds
of very high dose ivf and the dhea study
as well as these other factors i'm a
woman
i had had one baby at that time i
had failed in breastfeeding i had had a
you know
pretty normal menstrual history um
i had drank quite a bit of alcohol and
you know i'm an urban female in the
united states so i'd have
plenty of photo estrogen exposure now
this is the piece that i
believe should be added to intakes
my sister most importantly had had um
an emergency ovarian removal when she
was
about 14 years old and after that
her she got in pain her ovary was about
as big as a grapefruit she had emergency
surgery and ever since then she's had
severe endometriosis so that was you
know
the first clue about my estrogen
metabolism function if you
go back uh one of my aunts uh
was infertile or that was the given
explanation
we my mother didn't appear to have any
background
her sister had a lot of
painful fibroid tumors she ultimately
had an early hysterectomy she had
endometriosis
and my great aunt which is actually the
same age as my
aunt was also infertile and i don't have
any information about my grandmother
uh so so you have a lot of people
that you know there were clues to the
estrogen metabolism dysfunction
um and so this is a recent study
um that a very recent study which is on
uh my website which talks about
how endothermic carbonyl and then
may reduce the risk of hormone depending
cancers
um and i think that
my other point is that it may actually
improve the prognosis
of women with breast cancer so i really
strongly encourage you
for you those of you who are interested
in pursuing this in your
in your practices to go do
listen to some of the videos and pulled
out some of the studies on my website
so me uh as a person with irregular
bleeding
would have classified here
as someone who had many mutations and
significant very significant prior
estrogen use as well as
exogenous uh exogenous exposure
so i'm going to keep talking about media
and now
i have a breast uh i have breast cancer
so now
if i had come into your practice i think
i think you know it's very very
important for me based on a lot of
questions i've had in the past
and is that to to state that improving
estrogen function for a breast cancer
patient is always always always
an adjunct treatment to be added on
after all traditional treatment is
is completed there is a lot of
controversy about adding antioxidants
while under traditional
cancer therapy and i think um i think
that
taking the conservative line and
not doing these interventions during
standard treatment
is the is the path forward
so now i've told you already about my
breast cancer diagnosis
what i'd like to show you is how my
chart is looking
so now we can add me
with a very aggressive breast cancer to
my family history chart
and if i were doing a new intake we can
just add my very aggressive breast
cancer
with my unacceptable to me prognosis
um to my family history
and uh what i'd like to show you
now well let me let me just talk about
this this is another very interesting
study that was just presented
at the annual meeting for american
cancer research where they have found
they have found now these women were not
actually having
uh any interventions but in this study
what they found
based on all these women who they
followed up for 18 years which is why
it's very interesting this is uh based
on the
long island breast cancer study so these
women were followed for 18 years
and those of the women who had
less who had better estrogen health or
better estrogen metabolism ratios
um assuming i'm i'm assuming
that had they been genetically tested
you would find that those women had less
mutations
um then the ones had a better
mortality outcome
so um i think that adding
adding the interventions to improve your
estrogen health can help you
and you know improve your breast cancer
requirements
now this is what happened to me this is
not a full case study but i just want to
i want to conclude my own case history
with um with
what happened in my family so i was
diagnosed in
2009 and six years later my
father was diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer
and he was given uh he had
a whipple surgery successful
chemotherapy he was given 18 months to
live
which is the standard diagnosis from
point
of diagnosis um and
uh he basically died
just within his statistical uh
outcome for you know prognosis my mother
halfway through my father's pancreatic
cancer was diagnosed with a strange
small cell endometrial cancer in 2016
and which had metastasized everywhere so
she was stage 4
at diagnosis and she
wound up doing traditional therapy which
was not
not achieving results and then wound up
doing various immunotherapy
trials and died more than three years
later which was far
far past her prognosis so that is a
plug for immunotherapy and
um and i think it's important to
take that extended family history so you
can really see
how much estrogen metabolism dysfunction
both both my mother's cancer and my
father's cancer is strongly estrogen and
estrogen driven and uh and
in my case so because i'm high risk i
wound up having
a hereditary genetic testing my mother
had no
hereditary genes for her cancer neither
did my father and then later
i was run up as someone who was high
risk for pancreatic cancer
and i have known none of the currently
identified genes
for um for hereditary cancer
there's actually new there's new
research coming out on and
as an aside there's new research coming
out on endometrial cancer
at early stages which is looking at over
200 genes
to try and identify which of those may
may
indicate higher risk and some of the
genes that are indicating higher risk of
the endometrial cancers are estrogen
metabolism genes
not modifiable so
so i i know i'm running out of time i
just want to spend
a few minutes talking about
other case studies and how using genetic
testing can allow a physician to treat
women with more precision
so um
so here's an example of a 40 year old
woman
her mother died from breast cancer and
it's been my experience that it's only
women who have breast cancer
history of some form in their family
that know
about the dangers of estrogen exposure
very anxious about taking
either hrt or bioidentical hormones but
has severe very menopausal symptoms
and wants to wants to find out if she
can safely take them
if the uh estrogen gene metabolism
testing is conducted this patient in
particular only had one variation
on cyp1b1 so she can safely be given
an intervention to help her her very
menopausal
and i assume menopausal symptoms so
she's falling on the very low risk
here is an example of a 55 year old
woman who has been taking from pearl for
five years she comes in
and is wondering about her own breast
cancer risk
turns out that this woman has variations
on on seven genes
putting her in a um
a higher risk many mutations or
deletions and prior estrogen use
um and so the recommendations are to
stop
stop the prem crumb add dimpro the
omegas
are an antioxidant talk about some
lifestyle changes regarding
organic food or not living next to a
highway
avoiding you know eating barbecue every
day
um be it as it may based on the genetic
test results and then monitor the doses
until this woman is is showing some form
of improvement in her metabolic function
through urine testing
another example is a 35 year old woman
who wants to begin in vitro
fertilization this woman this square
gets very complicated because
having a baby is involved this woman has
mutations
on seven seven genes
and so one of the things that happens
when you're doing ivf is people
do breast cancer screening to see if
you're clear
um and
this would allow physicians in that
field to to
determine how much uh how much fertility
treatments they actually want to
prescribe perhaps they want to do one
and see what happens um
but this woman is not a candidate for
doing a dozen treatment i actually know
several women who have done literally a
dozen
a dozen rounds of ivf in their requests
to have a baby
and so this person is certainly not a
candidate for that and even if she's
going to have one treatment she can be
followed closely
or she can have that conversation about
egg donors or adoption earlier
there's a new treatment which is up also
in my
website where a cancer patient did not
the physicians chose not to give her
fertility treatments
to risk increasing her breast cancer
worsening her prognosis
and so they just went in and she was a
young woman they just went in directly
without giving her uh without giving her
the medications and were able to
retrieve octites and
mix them grow them in the lab and
after her treatment um impregnate
safely and i i think i think that in the
future this this will be the way
this is this will be what happens
particularly for you
so for that woman so she has she hasn't
actually had any prior estrogen
news she's she's still here um
and after she has ivf should the
physicians choose to
proceed with that she can become here
where she can just be monitored
more aggressive
and finally here um this is the last one
i'm going to talk about
is a 60 year old woman with estrogen
receptor positive breast cancer
she has variations on five genes which
are
is certainly no known
surprise for any estrogen receptor
positive breast cancer patients and so
in addition to continuing her aromatase
inhibitor she will add
jumbo omegas or the antioxidants and
uh you know with someone who's
post-menopausal
once the dosing requirements are are
showing an indication of improvement
that metabolite testing can happen
yearly
as part of annual checkup
uh oh there's one more and finally
a patient 35 year old with dcis
again no surprise that she has
variations on five genes
um she's uh it's been recommended that
she take a vista
so she's been taking vista she may be
put on tamoxifen
as a precaution she can improve her
estrogen metabolism and be tackling both
both of those pathways that we looked at
in the early
early slides so in conclusion
i am advocating that we have a
new protocols for standard care for all
women
but particularly for those women who are
in those
pools patient pools of higher risk i
encourage all of you to go to
my website at betterestrogen.com and
look at some of the studies
there's actually a white paper in there
that's maybe a few pages long which is
very very succinctly
reviews all of this information and
provides a lot of references for those
of you who would like to read
studies but what i'm advocating is that
the that the estrogen metabolism
dysfunction
on the extended family be added to
be added to traditional intake for women
and that
the estrogen metabolism genetic testing
be extended to as many women as possible
this all allows physicians to determine
specific
individual risks for both the
prescribing of estrogen-based
medications
and how aggressively someone has to be
monitored
i encourage you all again to to look at
this work
and wish you a very
happy and safe day